they went on talk yeah and sure enough
they put the
the casual room on top for less
expensive and sold it out
and we're also selling at the dining
room but then all of a sudden their
mater d's of which there were three
very traditional european guys started
telling the ownership
we hate this system this doesn't work
that doesn't work this doesn't work that
doesn't work
yeah and i was racking my brain going
man we've not heard this from any of
thousands of other restaurants something
weird is going on here
and what i figured out it was was that
those materials were making
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
of course
in cash tips and we have we eliminated
that now we've had the same problem with
night clubs
some nightclubs have gone on talk and
all of a sudden the various experiences
you want the dj booth experience
you know what so the owner is entitled
to that money
not the door person a thousand percent
sorry sorry
and you know what that that is
completely unfair that the the
tip of the spear you know skims the
cream and then everybody else is working
on the experience
as an owner so i really don't think it's
unethical for you to try
but as an owner it's my responsibility
to let that host or hostess know
why that's a bad practice for them to do
that and it has more to do with fairness
to the other folks around who might be
waiting or
i wonder if they pool the tips too
so they should mature but they could
also put it in their pocket nobody ever
know
thousand percent and we've definitely
had that happen and
and we've caught it and and because it
shouldn't go
front you're gonna catch it immediately
yeah of course yeah
so it should go to the whole staff by
the way definitely
see and so she thought it was unethical
that i did that and i explained to her
my wife would agree with her yeah i mean
i kind of agree with her
i kind of do agree with her it is like
but like you know it's a bit of a
marketplace and some people value the
tables more than others so i'm just
showing and indicating and that person
lives off tips and
but it was it's such an outrageous tip
for uh
yeah it's happens every day though for
sure it happens
all the time so looking at the
restaurant business today
um one observation i have is that
when i would go to korea or japan it was
pretty standard
to have a a red bell on the table you
could press the bell and get service
and it became increasingly standard you
know maybe even 10 15 years ago in japan
or whatever
to just pay um you know to order on your
phone or to pay with your phone
and the concept of a waiter even in you
know
more nice establishments went away
because of the shortage now
and with these qr codes for the i'm
seeing restaurants that
were absolutely driven by the waiter
experience
and being weighted on move to a runner
so you order it yourself you close out
your tab as you go
using whatever it is toast i think is
one popular one i don't know if you talk
has that
tacos what are your thoughts on
that and is that a trend that stays with
us and is it better for customers and
restaurants or worse
so well the better worst part is tricky
it's an experience thing right so i
think great service will never go fully
out of style right i mean there's
there's an art to that and it's a
wonderful hospitality experience to have
it
uh weirdly and this is a theory of mine
but i'm pretty confident in it
the reason why in europe and
asia that happened more quickly is
because credit card rates there
are so many basis points less they're
less than half
of of you know so and also card
present rates in the us are kind of like
two 2.1 percent for visa mastercard 3.1
percent for amex
card not present rates are 2.9 table
trust side transaction even if you use
this
they don't accept biometric data for it
so it's hard not present which means you
have to pay a higher amount
because they didn't run a piece of
plastic and so
consequently if you want a billion
dollar business
convince the credit card companies that
that is a dying thing
and here's how hard it is and how
entrenched it is
can you pay with apple pay walking out
of a restaurant right now
like tim cook once said apple pay is not
a success
until i can use it walking out the door
of my restaurant
but the reason that apple has not even
been able to force function that
is because all the pos systems are are
kind of already
you know embedded with like literally
wiring
in these systems and if you don't swipe
the credit card it's not a card present
transaction
and you're paid yeah yeah and so that's
crazy
and that's something that i'm working on
because
if you can unlock that if i can charge
heck i should be able to charge less
right right so so if i could charge two
percent
or i could do a direct ach payment
directly from the the from you jason
i can actually give you a one percent
discount if you just pay with the talk
app
and it goes right into the restaurant
it's amazing checking yeah we just
bypassed them all together
so used i've used the apple pay once or
twice in restaurants i was so delighted
by it
because you just look at your thing you
double click it's so easy it's
phenomenal
i i am a big fan of we're integrating
talk with apple pay in two weeks
um and we uh we have a partnership with
chase
so these are all things that you have to
do to start forcing the industry to go
hey maybe that is a card present
transaction
in today's startup landscape committing
to security and compliance is vital for
growth
and proof of your company's security
posture has never been
more important as you scale you might
start to receive more
sock2 requests from customers and that's
where drata
comes in drata is an advanced automation
platform used by some of the world's
leading chief
information security officers or csos
strata will help you successfully meet
requirements support enterprise deal
flow and continually track
compliance drata also helps customers
easily prepare for
and clear sock 2 and other audits so you
can go from zero to audit ready in a
matter of weeks
need more take it from philip martin
chief security officer at coinbase and
here's his quote
it became clear to me right away that
drata is an engineering powerhouse
the solution they've developed is well
ahead of other market players
their approach to deep native
integrations provides users with the
most advanced automation
available so check out drata's 5 star
reviews on g2
and see why companies like clear close
smart recruiter and
the good face project work with drata
for their compliance needs
twist listeners can get 15 off and
waived implementation fees at drata.com
twist